you're as happy right now as you're
going to be when you achieve this thing
in other words achieving the thing is
not going to make you happier it's just
going to put you back in the state that
you're in right now and achievements in
that sense is like an amplifier of
whatever you're feeling right now so if
you're feeling a sense of misery right
now and you achieve something amazing
the wave of Joy will pass and you'll be
back Mis miserable again but if you're
happy right now if you feel fulfilled
right now and you cultivate that then
you can achieve things and will still be
fulfilled and maybe even it'll inform
which goals you go after having
fulfillment now will make you think okay
well this opportunity is not aligned
with what I'm feeling inside so I'm
going to even though on on the surface
it looks glittery it looks amazing but
I'm going to pass that one and I'm going
to go for this one that doesn't look
glittery but it is aligned and you move
in that direction and usually that's
where amazing things start happening in
your life